the power of Hurricane Florence nearly
tore apart a hotel built out of cinder
blocks in Jacksonville North Carolina
overnight police and firefighters
managed to rescue about 60 people who
were staying there Adriana Diaz is in
Jacksonville which is just a few miles
from Camp Lejeune one of the largest
Marine Corps bases Adriana good morning
good morning John there are no words
that could describe what hurricane-force
winds could do that could top this
visual take a look at this this is a
massive 63 year old oak tree that was
toppled by Florence it happened last
night and believe it or not I don't know
if you can even tell there's a house
back there the people were in that house
this is a different house in the house
we showed you earlier today there is a
mother staying in this house she lives
there her son was staying there to keep
her safe they watched the tree come down
from their window and they said that it
fell almost in slow motion before
crashing into their neighbor's roof now
that neighbor he's been worried about
this house for years so he got out of
Dodge last night just in case but the
family here
they said they have minimal damage but
they have a lot of firewood now but make
no mistake this is a dangerous storm
this is one of several trees in this
neighborhood just on this block that
have been toppled and that is why
officials want people off the roads in
Jacksonville we are inland we're about
20 miles inland from the coast but it is
still extremely dangerous there's a
curfew that is in place it won't get
lifted until Sunday morning at 7 a.m.
Adriana boy that is such a graphic
example of how dangerous this storm is
and it brings up the question people say
depending on where you live whether you
should go to the roof go to the Attic of
your house or stay on the first floor
that's a perfect example of why you
should not go upstairs to the Attic if
that it hit the house it could be very
very dangerous for everybody living
inside
I'm thinking Adriana can't hear me but
what I was gonna what I was saying right
because these aren't deep-rooted tree
exactly and the water is loosening them
yes yes I remember in 1983 when
hurricane Alicia hit Houston our house
we had a beautiful oak tree in the
backyard mm-hmm it missed the house
luckily but was one of the first things
to fall and you've got oak trees and all
of these other trees that are not deep
rooted in the area which is why people
need to heed that warning don't go up
even when you think that's the right
thing and the soaking of the water in
the ground that makes it even worse the
trunk is so big you would think that
things where